i think people will be reassured to hear
that the government does have a plan b
as we move into autumn winter maybe
slightly surprised that we're calling it
plan b but to have one is is certainly
advantageous but given the briefing we
had from the chief medical officer
yesterday given the minutes from sage
from a week ago which were released
yesterday warning of 7 000
hospitalizations a day
why are we not moving to plan b
immediately
well look what we set out yesterday were
our plans to manage kovid over the
autumn and the winter we know that's the
time of year that you know covid 19
likes and other seasonal viruses like
flu so i think it's right for government
to reassure people that we have planned
for this our first line of defense
against covid remains our hugely
successful vaccine program that's
complemented by amazing new treatments
by our juggernaut of a testing system
our world-class surveillance system and
this is all working and that's allowed
us to make the gains that we've seen
over the last few months and return
you're almost to normal and alongside
that by the way we are also going to
have the biggest flu vaccination program
this country has ever seen so we need to
work and continue to plan for that we
also want to increase vaccine uptake
that's going to help over autumn and
winter and that's why yesterday i also
announced that we're going ahead with a
booster program for some 30 million
people starting next week and we're also
offering vaccines to 12 and 15 year olds
so i think taken together
this can protect the gains that we've
made we've got to remain cautious of
course but i think that's a good plan a
uh all of which all of which is entirely
laudable but we we knew all of that the
question remains why are we not moving
to more stringent measures now if we do
nothing if behavioral patterns do not
change if action continues then we are
on track to see hospitalizations
increasing significantly in the next
couple of weeks no i think it's i think
you might be there referring to the sage
report that you just mentioned obviously
there's other reports and things and
it's right that experts are looking at
what's happening and trying to come up
with their best guess of where things
might go based on certain assumptions
now my job as the health secretary and
and other ministers is to take all of
that together and and make the best
decision and that we can you know i
remind you that back when we made the
step four decision there were also uh
experts saying that you know case rates
are going to surge to 200 000 the
hospitalization is going to go 2 to 300
to 3 000 a day don't do it but we have
to listen to that but eventually make
what we think is the right decision and
there's no there is no risk-free
decision but i think what we've
announced in terms of this plan is is
well thought through it's the act of a
responsible government to set out this
is our plan this is what how we're going
to protect the gains but just in case
things are not quite as we would want
them to we've got to have another plan
and get that ready too completely agree
that there are no risk-free options but
there are riskier options and there are
there are options which are less risky
it does rather feel that we're in the
same situation we were this time last
year when sage were again warning that
there needed to be some kind of
intervention the government dithered and
dallied for two months before we got the
lock down and we know what happened
december and january in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths yes and i
think the big big difference this is
huge
are the vaccines i mean the vaccines are
working we know that they've already
stopped some 125 000 deaths some 140 000
hospitalizations some 25 million
infections and that is why we also want
more people as part of our plan to to
take the vaccine there's some six
million adults out there that still
haven't had a single jab and they may
well have been better spending the
summer trying to get as many of those
vaccinated as possible and that's and i
think it's great that we have got to
eighty-one percent of adults having
heavyweight colleagues have always
did previously say that the vaccination
program was the way out of this and
clearly that's not the case anymore well
i think if we can if we all look at
where we are today versus even at the
start of this year we've made huge
progress and the answer the reason for
that is the vaccines now it's not just
the vaccines on their own we can't just
rely on vaccines and that's why the new
treatments that we have in the nhs is
hugely important as part of our defense
our testing system where offer of a free
test you know that is identifying some
quarter of the positive cases that we
see on a daily basis and so when we get
those people to isolate that helps
protect not just them but those around
them our surveillance system it's the
best in the world and and how we now can
better look out for and track any new
variants and especially those that might
concern us so you're taken together
that's a very strong package that said
and if they are implying this i would
agree with this bit is that we need to
make sure that we've also got plans in
place just in case for example there is
some a new variant of concern let's say
highly infectious has some kind of
vaccine escape capability we've got to
prepare for that and have things ready
to go just in case so it is a new
variant the the trigger point for a move
to plan no i wouldn't i i i wouldn't i
mean a new and dangerous new variant you
know would be of of course a huge
significant concern but it doesn't there
could be other issues so for example
you know what happens in the nhs is
going to be hugely important to me to
the whole country making sure that we
don't get to a position again where the
nhs becomes unsustainable what has to do
with hospitalizations would be
unacceptable well i don't i think we're
going to have to look at a number of
measures which we already do working
closely with our friends in the nhs so
of course that would be the level of
hospitalization it will be the pressures
on a e the pressures on the workforce so
we'd have to take all of these together
and and obviously on a
you know daily basis you know talking to
our friends in the nhs to see uh how
they are coping with pressures now we
know at a winter time even in a normal
winter without covid it can get very
tough uh for the nhs now we've got a
layer covered on top of that and
and going into this winter i think we
just want to be as best prepared as we
possibly can do you now accept that you
were wrong to say back in june that the
relaxation of restrictions was was
irreversible i mean messaging at times
like this particularly in a public
health crisis is all important your
words will have had an effect on
people's behavior i i i like anyone else
i want the as we remove measures i want
it to be irreversible
but as we've said now i would say that
you said it was a reversible do you
accept no that you were wrong to state
that
was wrong i want them to be irreversible
and i think that you know what what i
was expressing then and what many people
have expressed a desire that we just
keep moving forwards that we don't have
to go backwards into measures that we
wish we'd just said goodbye to but
i think we just have to be
remaining cautious and i think what we
set out yesterday as a government our
plans uh to to keep up with the vaccine
program to keep up with the testing i
think these are the good solid measures
but we've got to continue to work
together as a country to protect the
gains that we've made sure but i think
the problem the problem is that the
messaging seems to veer between you know
one point in the day completely cautious
the other end of the day come completely
optimistic but let's just take one of
the one of the aspects from from plan is
as outlined by the prime minister
yesterday the advice that we should now
be wearing masks in in crowded places
masks in indoor situations mass when
mass when people
requested all of his according according
to chris whitty when you and your
cabinet colleagues met yesterday to
discuss and sign off on what the prime
minister said
how many of you were wearing masks you
can take a look at the picture that
we've got the the number 10 released
yesterday that they chose this picture
there's basically 38 to 40 people in
that room poorly ventilated not one
person is wearing a mask on the day that
you advise us to wear masks in
situations like that and that is uh
perfectly consistent with what the prime
minister said yesterday and what i said
yesterday because what we said was that
people should uh consider wearing masks
in crowded places when they are with
strangers when they are with people that
they are not normally spending your time
it's conservative back benches to be
wearing masks at pmq's later no they're
not they're not strangers you know this
is they the set of back benches whether
they're in parliament in the chamber
themselves itself or in their other
meeting rooms and things not catch calls
it's it's not it's it you have to take
measures that are appropriate uh for the
the prevalence of kobe at the time and
and with the with the
measures that we've taken with vaccines
with testing with surveillance and and
sensible use of masks when required and
you as we've suggested yesterday which
has been perfectly consistent by the way
with what we said at the time we entered
step four we took that step and we're in
the what i said at the time of that mask
with the prime minister said that hasn't
changed and so that messaging has been
consistent throughout and it's important
that we we set out as we have in this
plan about how we can work together to
protect these gains do you think more or
less people would wear masks if they saw
you wearing them around the cabinet
table
i i think look of course people are
influenced by others but every
individual should make the decision
based on the advice that they're given
and in the situation they find
themselves in at the time i mean
there is plenty of misinformation and
disinformation around it and as you and
your absolute right to point out that
people will take their lead from others
nicki minaj made some pretty baseless
claims on social media i'm not going to
ask about those specifically but i do
wonder whether or not you feel the
social media companies are doing enough
that tweet by nicki minaj remains up
this morning i don't want to draw
attention to such ridiculous tweets but
the
people that are in in the public eye you
know whether they are a a a a celebrity
or a politician or whatever they are
they should be very careful uh with
their language and and certainly to not
be spending on truths and i think what
the what the chief medical officer said
was absolutely right i i think everyone
would agree with you that people in in
public positions should be very very
careful with their language i do wonder
then what you make of the comments that
have come to light michael gove not when
he was a student as some suggested but
when he was in his twenties he used the
term fuzzy wuzzy's to describe black
people
what is going on in this government what
should happen to him look i i know my i
don't know anything about that
particular report whether he did before
but he did not remarks at the time i
don't know whether he did or did not say
that what i do know i didn't know
michael gove in his 20s but i do know
him now and i think you'd find it hard
to come across anyone in the government
that is uh so inclusive and and
celebrates the kind of britain that we
are today sure but but if a member of
the english cricket first 11 had made
those remarks in his 20s he'd be ejected
from the side and he'd be suspended from
cricket it feels like the bar for
acceptable language for a minister for
the crown is lower than that for a guy
who hits a ball with a bat
professionally look i don't agree with
you look i as i said i've i've told you
with my experience with michael gove i
think we're lucky to have him and
everything that he does in in government
makes a huge difference every day but in
terms of those particular remarks
obviously i didn't know him in his 20s
i'm not even familiar with that
particular report but you could try and
invite him on your program and see what
he has to say except you won't be drawn
on that i do want then want to conclude
on the decision by by the speaker of the
house of commons to in essence ban the
the chinese ambassador from speaking
from a diplomatic from a political
standpoint do you agree with that
decision well first of all it's a
decision for parliament
government what do you make of it i i
think that
given that the the chinese government
has banned british parliamentarians i
find that unacceptable there is
absolutely wrong for the chinese
government to ban british
parliamentarians and you for calling out
the gross human rights violations that
take place in that country
and and that's the yeah and i can see
why parliament represented by the
speaker and the lord speaker might have
made this decision
uh minister great to have you on the
program you've got a very busy day so we
will let you go thank you very much
thanks for having me